uh russian reservists will probably be
getting a notice uh within the next 24
hours or so about them needing to report
to military bases to begin training to
then go fight uh in ukraine uh we're
also hearing that perhaps active duty
russian military personnel
that are already fighting we're hearing
most likely will have their contracts
extended indefinitely as long as this
special military operation in ukraine as
it's referred to by moscow continues
to
[Music]
also important to note that what else
vladimir putin mentioned is he's also
confirming that they're going to push
forward with referendums happening in
different territories here in ukraine
territories that are fully or partially
controlled by the russian military
including the don bass region of donetsk
and luhans those referendums are
expected to happen as early as later
this week ukrainians in those
territories will be asked one question
do you want to join the russian
federation
this is usually the first step or
perhaps if you how you look at it
perhaps the last step before russia
pursues full annexation the view from
key isn't any any uh annexation or even
referendum is in their words simply a
sham and we've already heard from
officials in western capitals as well
saying that any referendum here in
ukraine would simply not be recognized
by many western allies in ukraine
[Music]
you